est également un grand sujet vous
voulons moderniser l'industrie
afin d'assurer la prospérité et la
protection climatique sur le bras
et nous voulons avancer dans ce sujet il
existe également des couteaux trait aux
questions à l'ordre du jour qui sont
également de tout
un tas la défense de l'état de droit et
de la démocratie
nous allons en discuter au cours des
choses
s'agissant du climat un grand thème
concerne les activités que nous pouvons
plus lié avec ceux qui nécessaire
internationale
l'europe inscrit ses activités dans
l'esprit d'une protection au niveau des
frontières de l'industrie
cela rentre également
en parallèle d'un club climatique
il s'agit d'encourager la coopération
internationale afin qu'elle soit
particulièrement fructueuse
dans un contexte difficile à la
frontière entre la russie et l'ukraine
la coopération est particulièrement
important
il est important que tout soit mis en
oeuvre afin que
la situation
se développe autrement quand on peut le
craindre à présent
nous sommes engagés pour une désescalade
et nous sommes tous unanimes une
agression militaire auraient des
conséquences graves
les relations bilatérales sont tous de
bonnes choses les relations et le
travail au sein de l'union européenne
de l'otan et de l'ouest s'est senti une
bonne chose c'est ce que je crois il
s'agira à l'avenir de continuer dans
cette voie
car cela est vrai également dans le
contexte du format merlan dit oui dans
lequel au sein duquel l'allemagne et la
france sont un rôle important
nous engageons pour un multilatéralisme
au niveau des relations franco
allemandes mais également au niveau
international merci et merci emmanuel
macron pour ta présence
chancelier chaire l'afp merci beaucoup
pour l'accueil en ce début d'année à la
chancellerie je suis heureux de te
retrouver de retrouver l'ensemble des
équipes et de pouvoir travailler et
juste te remercier pour cette invitation
à berlin après notre première rencontre
officielle à paris le 10 décembre
dernier avant toute chose je tiens à
présenter les condoléances de la france
suite à l' attaque menée hier par un
forcené à heidelberg et à dresser ici
mes voeux de prompt rétablissement aux
blessés et mes condoléances à la famille
de la jeune étudiante qui a été tué
q le rappeler depuis le 1er janvier
l'allemagne et la france ont
respectivement pris la présidence
du g7 et du conseil de l'union
européenne ce qui au delà de la force de
notre relation bilatérale et de l'agenda
commun que nous menons l'un et l'autre
nous permettre de coordonner de nombreux
agenda régionaux et internationaux
je ne reprendrai pas tout ce que
monsieur le chancelier a indiqué nos
fonds d'abord nous voulons ensemble
construire une économie du futur qui
soit plus juste plus forte sur le plan
numérique et mieux régulé
adaptés
permettant d'apporter notre réponse au
changement climatique
et cet agenda prochains semaines va nous
permettre de le faire à beaucoup
d'égards sur le plan climatique par les
avancées de nos discussions européennes
notre travail à la fois quant au
mécanisme d'ajustement carbone aux
frontières et notre club des amis du
climat la présidence
de l'union européenne l'autre dans le
cadre du g7 ce qui permettra d'articuler
les différents formats européens et
internationaux particulier celui de l'
ocde comme nous avons su le faire pour
la taxation numérique donc nous avons la
volonté d'avoir un agenda climatiques
très volontariste et de pouvoir mettre
en cohérence des sujets internationaux
avec celui ci c'est le même agenda que
nous pousserons ensemble dans quelques
semaines lors du sommet un océan à brest
qui nous permettra sur les sujets de
biodiversité d'océan de pousser le
modèle européen
cette économie du futur que j'évoque
c'est une économie aussi plus numérique
avec une série de projets
d'investissement que nous allons pousser
durant les mois qui viennent ensemble et
sur lesquels nous allons continuer de
travailler des semi conducteurs à
l'intelligence artificielle pour ne
citer que quelques exemples mais qui
vont nous conduire aussi à faire
cheminer ensemble plusieurs régulation
structurantes celle sur les marchés
celles sur les services numériques en
même temps que nous devons parachever un
modèle commun que nous aurons à
travailler ensemble sur les bons
investissements et des bonnes
la bonne gouvernance économique et
financière de notre europe pour
accompagner ce volontarisme économique
deuxième grand thème ce sera évidemment
celui de l'europe des valeurs et les
combats qui nous sont chères nous savons
que dans les prochains mois nous aurons
ensemble à gérer des situations
qui sont parfois préoccupante dans
certains états membres de l'union
européenne et nous nous ferons avec
beaucoup de respect et en particulier le
respect de chaque gouvernement
souverainement élus mais en même temps
avec beaucoup d'exigence pour le respect
des valeurs de notre europe et le combat
pour nos valeurs et les combats qui sont
chères aux européens
c'est aussi les combats pour un salaire
minimum européen
d'égalité femmes hommes qui vont scander
l'agenda européen des prochains mois est
marquée en particulier plusieurs sujets
de coopération entre l'allemagne et la
france et puis le troisième grand sujet
à mes yeux qui a été largement évoquée
par monsieur le chancelier
c'est évidemment
l'union européenne jouant son rôle de
puissance d' équilibre et les sujets
régionaux et géopolitique que nous
aurons à gérer ensemble dans ce contexte
nous aurons à travailler ensemble avec
le continent africain dès le sommet du
mois prochain entre l'union africaine et
l'union européenne et nous les aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir ce soir et une
volonté de bâtir un partenariat nouveau
qu'il s'agisse des questions de vaccins
jusqu aux questions de transition
climatique et de réformes économiques et
financières avec le continent africain
comme au sujet de sécurité de lutte
contre le terrorisme
et puis nous aurons la question des
balkans sur laquelle nous voulons avoir
un agenda commun dans les mois qui
viennent je tiens beaucoup à notre notre
collaboration étroite les balkans
occidentaux sont un sujet d'importance
pour la paix la stabilité de l'europe et
comme vous l'avez rappelé un instant
comme tu l'a parfaitement digéré la fdt
nous y reviendrons ce soir mais nous
avons ensemble à gérer évidemment les
tensions qui aujourd'hui sont
croissantes à la frontière ukrainienne
et plus largement la question de la
relation avec la russie et nous appelons
l'un et l'autre avec beaucoup de force à
une désescalade détention et je veux ici
dire combien l'allemagne et la france
sont unis sur ce sujet qu'il s'agisse
des discussions que nous avons dans le
cadre de l'otan de l'union européenne au
sein de la bce mais aussi comme étant
les deux partenaires européens du format
des deux normandie sur tous ces sujets
nous jouons notre rôle pour avoir
véritablement une europe qui travaillent
sur le contrôle des armements et un
nouvel ordre de sécurité de stabilité
pour elle même pour appeler à la
désescalade par un dialogue exigeant
avec la russie et pour travailler à une
stabilité par une solution politique sur
la question du don basse et la situation
en ukraine tout ça exige une très grande
unité coordination c'est le cas entre
l'allemagne et la france et c'est ce que
d'ailleurs nous avons aussi ensemble
fait hier soir avec plusieurs autres
pays européens
et alliés de l'otan et en particulier
des états unis d'amérique
je ne serai pas plus long je répondrais
éventuellement en question qui se pose
sur d'autres sujets je vais en tout cas
à nouveau monsieur le chancelier vous
remercier pour votre invitation
aujourd'hui à berlin et surtout pour le
travail permanent que nos équipes nos
ministres mais l'ensemble surtout pour
la relation d'amitié et de travail que
nous avons l'un l'autre merci je relève
bonjour monsieur le chancelier bonjour
monsieur le président une question donc
mathieu quoi je vais faire télé pour les
télévisions françaises on a bien entendu
de votre appel à une désescalade
détention il se trouve que la russie a
lancé aujourd'hui des manoeuvres
militaires à la frontière ukrainienne et
en crimée quel est le niveau de cette
menace aujourd'hui selon vous estimez
vous que l'armée russe peut entrer sur
le territoire dans les heures ou dans
les dents les minutes dans les parts non
dans les jours qui viennent et si
c'était le cas on a du mal à comprendre
quelles réponses la france l'allemagne
et plus généralement les européens
seraient prêts à porter les américains
déploient 8500 militaires en état d'
alerte est ce que l'armée française est
ce que l'allemagne est prête elle aussi
intervenir dans le cadre de l'otan
militairement bonjour merci
merci pour cette question
je verrai ce que nous avons
été clairs sur le fait que toute
agression militaire menaçant l'intégrité
territoriale de l'ukraine aurait des
conséquences graves et serait payé au
prix fort
nous sommes en contact avec nos alliés
au sein et à mieux repérer
dit
que nous pouvons également invité
d'autres façons afin d
escalade
soutenir ardemment un format de
discussions directes entre notamment les
états unis et la russie qui
puisse y avoir des rencontres et des
discussions autant cela ne se faisait
plus depuis longtemps c'est à nouveau le
cas c'est une bonne chose
oui c'est en tout cas
ce vrai
que l'oas et oeuf pour des négociations
est une organisation qui vise à éviter
les guerres et à limiter les tensions
souveraineté et l'intégrité territoriale
des états européens ne doit pas être
remise en question ce sont des principes
mais et donc il s'agit de format de
négociations très intéressant nous avons
déjà par exemple évoqué le format
normandie et c'est ainsi que nous devons
procéder de deux vont prendre la
situation sérieusement car elle est
sérieuse
nous devons d'autre part être clair sur
les conséquences une agression militaire
ce que nous avons fait enfin
troisièmement nous devons également dans
le même temps faire tout notre possible
afin de mener des discussions des
négociations
cela se fait dans un cadre de
coopération très étroite avec les états
unis et c'est un bon développement dans
une situation très complexe
par rapport à la situation et aux
derniers
événements nous demeurons extrêmement
vigilant et le consenti n a défait du
mans caractérisée et est qualifié mais
nous sommes collectivement très
vigilants nous suivons en temps réel la
situation et son évolution et nous
préparons toutes les formes de réaction
comme l'a dit monsieur le chancelier je
voudrais insister sur quatre éléments le
premier c'est l'unité des européens et
de leurs alliés face à cette situation
nous sommes totalement unie groupe et
coordonnée
en tant que pays membre de l'union
européenne en tant qu'allié au sein de
l'organisation du traité atlantique nord
la deuxième chose c'est notre solidarité
avec l'ukraine
un magnet france sont très clairement
solidaire et
la commission européenne a eu l'occasion
ces derniers jours d'annoncé des
réengagements à l'égard de l'ukraine
nous sommes tous vigilants aussi pour
protéger un point de vue cyber
l'ukraine qui a subi plusieurs attaques
ces dernières semaines et donc dans le
contexte de cette situation nous sommes
en solidarité avec l'ukraine est
pleinement engagée
troisième élément ce chancelier vient
d'insister sûr ce point c'est de ne
jamais abandonner le dialogue avec la
russie ait un dialogue exigeant vous
savez que la france a toujours plaidé
pour ce dialogue ce dialogue relève de
plusieurs formats il ya un dialogue il
est structurant est important entre les
états unis d'amérique et la russie il
est bon qu'il se poursuive il y à un
dialogue qui donnera lieu d'ailleurs à
des réunions prochaine et qui a donné
lieu à des premiers échanges dans un
format que nous connaissons entre la
russie et l'otan
il ya un dialogue
dans le cadre de l' os c'est eux mais si
le chancelier de vient de rappeler
l'importance de ce format qui je le
rappelle est né en effet d'il ya trente
ans notre volonté de construire un
espace de sécurité commun en europe et
qui est la conséquence
de valeurs et de principes que nous
avons acceptées nous européens mais la
russie également et parmi ces principes
que nous avons accepté dans l'océan est
aussi garant il y à la souveraineté de
chacune et chacun et en particulier de
l'ukraine est donc le dialogue dans le
cadre de l' eau et co2 se poursuivre il
ya le dialogue dans le cadre du format
normandie sur la question on craignait
des duos des accords de minsk et il ya
le dialogue entre l'union européenne et
la russie
chacun de ces canaux doit être doit être
exploité jusqu'au bout pour réengager la
russie dans un processus de désescalade
obtenir des garanties et nous permettre
aussi de bâtir ce que j'ai pu appeler ce
nouvel ordre de sécurité de stabilité
mais c'est à dire des dégager des
garanties au delà de la question
ukrainienne sur la sécurité aux
frontières de notre europe et puis de
quatrième élément c'est que nous
préparons en parallèle la réaction
commune et la riposte en cas d'agression
et comme cela a été dit s'il devait y
avoir une agression
la riposte sera là et le coût sera très
élevé
c'est un succès sur votre unité
début de votre coopération
entre chancelier est présent n'était pas
particulièrement difficile car il y a
beaucoup de différences au niveau
bilatéral
par exemple
l'exportation des arguments ou la france
et l'allemagne ont des points de vue
différents et encore bien d'autres
sujets
donc comment estimez-vous l'état de
votre coopération est elle vraiment
difficile partie en bonne
peut être établir une coopération
entre l'état de votre coopération avec
monsieur schultz et madame merkel est il
plus facile plus compliqué
d'abord je veux dire que nous avons déjà
travaillé avec le chancelier should
parle le passé puisque
il a eu aussi à un vrai lac à fond sur
beaucoup de sujets très structurant en
particulier le fameux plan de relance
européen ou à l'époque en tant que
ministre des finances il a eu un rôle
extrêmement important auprès de ses
prédécesseurs et donc ce n'est pas non
plus une découverte nous connaissions et
je crois que l'agenda
germaneau français l'agenda européen est
connue de l'un de l'autre il ya déjà eu
des travaux communs à travers le les
tempes dans nos conditions successives
je veux dire d'abord que nous nous
sommes l'un et l'autre profondément
convaincu
de l'importance de l'amitié entre
l'allemagne et la france et du rôle
absolument nécessaire et structurant de
cette entente pour faire avancer
l'europe
ensuite
la prise de responsabilité de monsieur
le chancelier arrive dans un moment qui
est très difficile pour tous nos pays
la crise sanitaire est là
qui vient frapper le pays qui nous
imposent de continuer à réagir à un vrai
le contexte géopolitique notre échange
le montre depuis tout à l'heure est
tendue d'une manière inédite et donc je
crois que nous sommes l'un et l'autre
animé par la conscience que nous devons
ensemble bâtir des solutions
ensuite tout ce que vous avez dit est
juste nous avons des différences parce
que l'allemagne n'est pas la france et
la france n'est pas l'allemagne est pour
nous une découverte pas tellement mais
nous avons une conviction c'est qu'il
faut oeuvrer à bâtir des compromis et ne
jamais laisser s'installer de désaccord
ou de malentendus c'est ça la
responsabilité qui est la nôtre
sur les sujets d'énergie nos modèles
sont différents puisque il procède à la
fois d'une histoire différente et de
choix qui ont été conduits dans les 15
dernières années profondément différent
pour autant nous devons ensemble réussir
un agenda de décarbonation de nos
économies et bâtir une plus grande
souveraineté énergétique européenne nous
saurons nous entendre
la commission a fait une proposition
elle fait l'objet de remarques les
choses vont cheminer je ne crois pas
qu'il y ait quoi que ce soit de
rédhibitoire et l'allemagne à un modèle
et un chemin et la france a le sien mais
tout nous puissions utilement coopérer à
porter nos contributions à ce projet
européen nous avons historiquement des
différences sur le plan
des discussions économiques et
financières
néanmoins
l'euro tout ce que nous avons su flairer
le plan de relance n'aurait jamais été
possible s'il n'y avait à chaque fois
pas eu d'accord entre l'allemagne et la
france c'est ce que nous saurons faire
et donc pour pouvoir dire que nous
sommes attachés à des règles de sérieux
budgétaire à l'intégrité de la zone euro
aux convergences qu'elle impose et dans
le même temps nous sommes lucides sur
les nécessités d'investissement que
requiert l'environnement qui est le
nôtre qu'il s'agisse des sujets
militaires des sujets climatique ou des
sujets numériques c'est cet équilibre
qu'il nous faut bâtir et inventer les
solutions nouvelles sur le sujet de
l'export d'armement je sais la
sensibilité de cette question dans la
vie politique allemande
ça n'est pas non plus une nouveauté
puisqu'il ya quelques années avec la
chancelière merkel nous avons bâti
justement des règles communes les
espagnols d'ailleurs ont rejoint direct
que nous avions su bâtir et je suis
confiant sur le fait que nous trouverons
toujours des solutions pragmatiques
donc oui nous ne sommes pas les mêmes
mais nous ne l'avons jamais été
mais diable qu'est ce que nous nous
rapprochons à chaque fois c'est ce que
nous avons envie de faire ensemble je
crois pouvoir le dire
quant au couple parce qu'on parle
toujours de couple franco-allemand au
german aux français
il ya eu d'autres présidents avant moi
et il ya eu d'autres chancelier avait
avant le chancelier choc l'important est
que nous sachions bâtir une relation
singulière qui sera le fruit
de l'amitié entre nos pays des
circonstances et de tempérament je peux
vous dire que connaissant olaf scholz
depuis quelques années je suis confiant
sur notre capacité à consolider cette
amitié et à bâtir ensemble
je donne merci beaucoup
reste pas grand chose à rajouter de
mâcon tête deux ou trois remarques je
pense également que la relation entre la
france et l'allemagne est d'une grande
importance pour nos de tennis
et c'est pourquoi il faut s'assurer que
cette amitié se poursuit dans l'avenir
et nous l'avons déjà pratiqué entre nous
deux
nous avons une tâche en europe il faut
s'assurer que l'union européenne se
porte bien et nous en sommes toujours
plus responsables
nous le connaissons effectivement déjà
depuis longtemps
déjà à l'époque où j'étais maire nous
étions rencontrés
et nous nous étions a chargé des
relations culturelles des deux pays puis
en tant que ministre des finances
et en matière de relance au niveau
européen effectivement non seulement au
niveau de nos pays mais également
au niveau de l'europe nous avions
travaillé
et nous avons même travaillé de manière
très étroite au niveau personnel
et nous pensons donc qu'à l'avenir cette
relation se poursuivra
le président monsieur le chancelier une
question d'abord pour monsieur le
chancelier et choles
le refus de votre gouvernement de livrer
des armes à l'ukraine suscite de vives
critiques ces derniers jours les
autorités ukrainiennes
accusé l'allemagne de trahison tout à
l'heure le premier ministre polonais
s'est dit inquiet et déçu par l'attitude
de l'allemagne le gouvernement letton
parle quant à lui d'une grosse erreur
que leur répondez vous et que pouvez
vous dire aux ukrainiens pour les
rassurer et puis autre question deuxième
question qui s'adresse à tous les deux
quel est d'après vous
l'objectif final que poursuit vladimir
poutine dans cette affaire s'agit-il de
restaurer l'ordre russes dans ce qu'on
appelle son étranger proche
est-ce que ses ambitions dépassent la
sphère d'influencé traditionnelle de de
la russie c'est évidemment important de
savoir ce que vous répondez à cette
question parce que toute la stratégie
vous mettez en oeuvre dépend aussi de
des objectifs
prêté à la russie
sauf qu'ils
répondent d'abord ceux en ce qui
concerne l'allemagne le gouvernement a
refusé plusieurs demandes d'exportation
d'armes et il y a des raisons qui sont
liées à l'histoire des décennies passées
mais nous avons mené beaucoup d'actions
pour renforcer l'économie et la
démocratie en ukraine
est également dans le cas althea
responsabilité internationale qui nous
incombe
nous avons mené des actions par exemple
pour prolonger des contrats afin de
soutenir l'ukraine
et de ne pas l'abandonner de ne pas
abandonner à nos responsabilités
mais il faut prendre également ses
engagements en matière d'engagement de
l'ukraine en matière d'hydrogène par
exemple le
sait qu'elle peut se fier à l'allemagne
et je pense que c'est également le cas
dans ce contexte
les spéculations de vladimir poutine il
n'est peut-être pas pertinent de
spéculer à ce sujet
là aussi s'est exprimé à exprimer son
opinion pour nous il est clair que les
fondements de la sécurité et de la
coopération sont importants et que nous
devons respecter les décisions prises
collectivement au niveau de l'ouest
c'est eux ou au niveau d'autres
organisations internationales
et entre autres principes on trouve par
exemple l'intégrité territoriale et la
souveraineté des états d'europe
quant à votre question
m'appartient pas de dire
quel est l'objectif
final de la russie mais de constater
qu'il ya aujourd'hui une multiplication
de d'actes de déstabilisation
à l'encontre de plusieurs états
souverains
qui était anciennement partie de l'union
soviétique
et qu'il y ait en parallèle de la
multiplication de ces actes de
déstabilisation une approche de plus en
plus hybride de la russie
moldavie ukraine biélorussie caucase
attaque cyber utilisation de larmes de
la menace des migrations
manoeuvres militaires etc
et la situation dans laquelle nous
sommes donc aujourd'hui
n'est pas stabilisée c'est un premier
élément de conséquence il me fait dire
que ne sommes pas un état final qui est
lisible elle est préoccupante pour les
européens
et
elle impose cette unité et la
préparation d'une réaction commune qui
sera
gradué en fonction de l'avancée de ces
manoeuvres
mais elle conduit aussi à avoir un
dialogue de clarification avec la russie
car je pense que ce dialogue s'impose
pour essayer de lever les ambiguïtés
très clairement
nous pouvons aujourd'hui que constater
que la russie est en train de devenir
une puissance de déséquilibre
dans le caucase aux confins de l'europe
et dans quelques autres régions
m
le president
chancelier ma question
avait vu les différents formats de
discussions avec la russie demain se
rencontrent pour la première fois depuis
très longtemps
les membres du format
ces informations
n'avaient pas permis de beaucoup avancé
au cours des dernières années et on
avait plutôt l'impression que la russie
préféré se tourner vers la les états
unis et l'otan donc d'où ma question
à quel niveau estimez vous les chances
de succès et ne pensez vous pas qu'il
pourrait s'agir d'un alibi pour la
russie monsieur le président je lui pose
également cette question
qu'au cours des jours à venir quels
seront vos exigences fort qu est
concrète à vis à vis de la russie est
pourquoi
les dialogues
se font-ils à 2 et pourquoi
ne l'avez vous pas également d'autres
pays pour retrouver ce même format
normandie
bien sûr votre première question je
pense que d'abord il ne faut jamais
abandonner ses formats de discussion et
des changes
vous avez raison de dire que les
résultats du format normandie ne sont
pas à la hauteur des attentes et de
l'engagement que l'allemagne et la
france ont pu y placer
néanmoins abandonné renoncer c'est acté
que la solution politique n'est plus sur
la table donc je pense qu'il est
important nous de rester engagées sans
relâche la dernière réunion qui s'est
tenue en décembre 2019 au niveau des
chefs d'état de gouvernement avaient
permis des avancées robuste je pense que
la perspective d'une réunion futur la
réunion de nos conseillers diplomatiques
demain et la perspective d'une réunion
futur qui sera organisée qui sera cette
fois ci a organisé en allemagne
je pense créer des attentes positif et
permet de réengager les choses j'en veux
pour preuve d'ailleurs les gestes de
bonne volonté qui ont été faits par les
ukrainiens sur la loi qui était le
projet de loi qui était justement
critiqué par la russie et les échanges
qui lie entre nos conseillers sur chacun
de ces sujets la question est est ce
qu'on arrive à créer à nouveau une
dynamique positive donc je pense que
c'est important de continuer dans ce
format d'un bandit carrés au moins il
c'est le seul moyen d'éviter parfois la
désagrégation c'est le seul format
politique et c'est le seul moyen de
continuer à rester engagés à côté de ça
il ya une discussion entre les états
unis et la russie qui s'est engagée plus
récemment est ce que c'est une bonne
chose à nos yeux oui c'est une très
bonne chose que les états unis
d'amérique dispute avec la russie est ce
que pour autant cette discussion a donné
des résultats concrets à ce stade je
n'en ai pas vu parce qu'une discussion
avec la russie c'est toujours difficile
en ce qui me concerne ayant réengager
celle ci en 2010 9 et le 10 ans avec
beaucoup d'humilité j'ai pu le constater
mais je pense que c'est important de là
aussi garder ses canaux de discussion
c'est ce qui d'ailleurs avait conduit la
chancelière merkel et moi même il ya
quelques mois a poussé les européens là
aussi à rouvrir une discussion structuré
avec la russie c'est dans ce contexte et
avec la même volonté
exigeante mais lucide que j'aurai un
échange vendredi matin avec le président
poutine ce n'est pas un déplacement
c'est un échange téléphonique
six déplacements est à un moment
envisagé je pense que le format que vous
avez décrit est à mes yeux un format
tout à fait pertinent et qu'ils puissent
y avoir véritablement une position
germano-française franco-allemande
assumer ensemble compte tenu de nos
responsabilités à l'égard de la russie
pour ce qui est de vendredi ce sera un
échange téléphonique qui aura pour but
de faire un point sur l'ensemble de la
situation et d'essayer de justement
obtenir de la visibilité
engager un dialogue exigeant et obtenir
des clarifications sur plus des points
qui d'ailleurs nous en occuper ce soir
et font l'objet aujourd'hui
de nos réflexions de nos travaux communs
est-ce qu'il
est difficile il faut s'assurer que tous
les points de contact tous les formats
soit utilisé le bras nous en avons enfin
quelques cinq drones de ma vie de la
grande hypocrisie
et s'agissant de la situation
en ukraine
il y est néanmoins une bonne chose que
de nombreux de nombreuses voies de
dialogue était ouverte alors même
qu'elle était au point mort depuis
longtemps
j'évoque ici également le temps loi c
est le format normandie il faut utiliser
tous ses moyens afin de garder un canal
de communication
afin de viser des progrès possibles je
suis heureux que nous en soyons arrivés
si loin je suis heureux
du rôle que nous avons joué au niveau de
ce format carte tout le monde n'aurait
pas pu le faire et c'est un point
positif dans une situation compliquée
nous avons réussi grâce à nos efforts à
avoir ce canal de communication
merci
merci beaucoup
et voilà pour la conférence de presse du
chancelier allemand olaf scholz et
d'emmanuel macron les deux hommes vont
désormais poursuivre les échanges autour
d'un dîner la france et l'allemagne qui
tiendront demain à paris avec la russie
et l'ukraine une réunion sur cette crise
ukrainienne des discussions dans le
cadre du format normandie c'est ce que
prône paris et berlin qui appelle à une
désescalade détention ainsi qu'au
dialogue avec moscou le président
français qui a par ailleurs annoncé un
échange téléphonique avec vladimir
poutine vendredi matin